bernard benhamou s'est désolé mais
[Musique]
avec moi
c'est pas un auteur
mais c'est génial
[Musique]
il faut compter sur les jeunes
français sus après
analyse de mémoire je sais plus comment
vous avez fait la
[Musique]
[Rires]
jsk mais qui
seront
arrêtées elle regarde moi je t'en
supplie c'est
[Musique]
regarde
car elle regarde
[Applaudissements]
me
dionne maintenant midi
ouais mais qu'est ce que tu fais quoi
valeur à part le vendredi j'ai le
vendredi avec toi dans l'enceinte 2,8 et
jeremy tan
super
derrière
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lui il avait qu'à rouler le mahler j'ai
su garder
mon fils
déjà plus à une apparition sur un mec
bien
soulac
[Musique]
on pense y
dormir ici pour être humain du hérisson
du mon ami
[Applaudissements]
vous vous rendez compte à quel point le
gars était hyper à l'aise en fait
utilisé mon bien sous et cyril qui
n'arrive pas à tenir une vanne moi je
voyais bien qu'il y avait un truc parce
qu'il sous marins mais évidemment voilà
derrière l'autre était très en forme il
réagit comme en bout j'y tiens je sais
pas mais avec votre petit cahier
d'écolier veulent c'est lola c'est bien
vous moi je pense que j'aurais tout de
suite ouvert à la fête pour parler aux
gars tout de suite et pour lui dire quoi
exactement comment tu vas mon gars tu en
voilà un bon gars vous pouvez me donner
une précision sur les dimensions et six
filles écoutent à l'homme est alors pour
être très honnête enfin je n'ai même pas
j'ai enlevé mes lunettes
photographie ça m'a sauté aux yeux